fillon passe le temps
mais aussi sur un bouton 0 à regarder
mutinés
[Musique]
ah bonjour j'ai en train de faire un
tableau de l'île aux enfants
enfin j'ai fait du moins je n'en suis
qu'au début je viens de faire une prose
marguerite jaunes et trois brins d'herbe
regardez tous les jours il a l'amour tu
sais pas moquette monte vite sur les
graphiques moi je suis ridicule et je ne
veux pas faire autrement j'ai peur des
souris mais qu'est ce que tu fais c'est
vrai que j'ai mis sur le banc yens sous
riche aussi sûrement pas d'abord j'aime
beaucoup les souris et puis la souris
c'est moi écoute tu te croit malin mais
ouais et alors moi tu été pêchées cette
idée de me faire peur avec une souris
cet après midi j'ai assisté dans la
salle des fêtes de l'île aux enfants à
la représentation d'un excellent
imitateur
j'ai appris à en faire autant ah bon je
peux tu aurais pu me prévenir quand même
enfin qu'est ce qui limitait d'autant
limit line up est également très bien
tous les animaux de la ferme et coûte
par exemple
[Musique]
enfin si je fais ce qui te dit oh mon
dieu qu'ils sont l'atout de suspense je
ne savais pas at elle pas l'on me tâte
rattraper derrière attraper les ai
laissées par son futur je vous renverrai
mais qu'est ce qui t'a qu'est ce qui
t'arrive qu'on a pris un coup de soleil
sur la tête mais mais mais nous
gazinière mais les animaux de la ferme
se sont enfuis je les ai entendus crier
nos jours de sa plainte attentes rosalie
la fermière maîtrise ou sont ils
viennent vous avez sûrement vu si tu
voyais comme tu es drôle mais pour ceux
ci devaient être payés en trop qu'il est
ok c'est mieux c'est vraiment très
intelligente des cdac des gens on ne te
fâche pas françois ils viennent me faire
la même force avec une souris ouais mais
c'est simulator imiter également des tas
d'autres choses étonnantes
par exemple un vieux train à vapeur et
écouter
kazemi à casimir je dois avouer c'est
formidable et gravures mon dernier carré
au but
jusque là je n'entends plus dû s'arrêter
et des crabes des personnes moins chers
amis je ne vois pas là matière à rire et
toi pourquoi les quarts du pib
enfin voyons nous venons d'échapper de
justesse à une catastrophe et au miel et
non messieurs les snobs en soi pour
cogner vous l'évidence vois un gars sont
censés en revoyant mené par les parents
de passer le train mais calmez vous
monsieur death note
c'est casimir qui me tel bruit la
locomotive qui oui je suis plus trop
imitateur du monde
là je dois avouer que tu est extrêmement
doué
enfin aux yeux de tous je passe pour un
nigaud merci kazemi ils n'étaient pas
fermées ces dix tomes à françois lavoie
il a fait la même chose d'autre en
premier oui j'ai un très grand
répertoire on sait pas une raison qui
avait pourtant prendre pour le le
meilleur des imitateurs
parce que moi avec mon talent et ma
classe naturelle je peux faire beaucoup
mieux
ah ben c'est bien allez-y oui alors à
l'unanimité puisque vous me demandez de
vous refaire la langue comme aux trois
lions tout c'est pas trés - c'est plutôt
rare
c'est même très mauvais me suis dit ce
moment alors allez-y
enfin que françois puisqu'on est
meilleur que moi allez-y faites nous le
bloc par exemple sur l'atlantique nord
alors le coq
oui complètement lui est plutôt mal
c'est parfois
ni l'un ni l'autre vous nega les
cazilhacois n'ont écouté françois j'ai
quelque chose à vous dire j'ai une une
idée c'est vrai monsieur disney mais moi
aussi
ah c'est peut-être la même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà merci maintenant mais c'est les
snobs
donnez moi un exemple de votre façon de
vous exprimer quand je ne sais pas à mon
sens par exemple le théâtre je les pique
mais il n'y a rien de plus élevé or les
y aller si le théâtre chez les pygmées
non non il y avait attaqué plus le tt
théâtre tu as tout ouvert tant chez les
pygmées le théâtre chez les pygmées
il n'y a rien de plus élevé très bien
c'est très bien comme ça a abondé à
votre tour maintenant imiter moi bonjour
casimir tu veux un bal ou non non je
suis juste un jeu beaucoup trop mondain
comme intonations en plus simple bonjour
casimir du vélo oui oui avoue jean
casimir
j'ai retrouvé un vélo whisky lamballe et
bonjour casimir tu veux ballon c'est pas
mal du tout ces dix neuf voilà casimir
qui arrive alors vite aller par là et
moi je vais à mes ballerines ont
françois c - et c'est moi qui vais au
ballon voyons ben oui oui vous êtes
françois et moi je suis monsieur julien
seleçao
oui j'ai le trac n'a pas eu le temps de
répéter la suite de notre trouble oui je
sais je sais je le traquer merci par et
cela donne de talent enfin ces jeunes et
qui le dit
bon si tu en place voilà casimir logique
[Musique]
alors je connais une autre imitation
c'est un troupeau de chameaux qui
découvrent qu'en non la marque d'une
oasis et desséchées écoute quasi bien ça
suffit j'ai du travail car deux ans un
peu pour demain d'abord je ne te dérange
plus je viens les voir qu'on soit
d'accord
[Musique]
dis-moi françois bonjour casimir tue 20
ballons nous remercie françois jean
casimir tirer un balle aux nounous
louche je ne veux pas ballon je t'assure
pour jean casimir tel un ballot mais
enfin je t'ai déjà dit non tu es sourd
ou quoi aux gens viendraient plus tard
je n'étais pas mal du tout qu'en pensez
vous dites moi monsieur du stop le
théâtre chez les pics mais il n'y a rien
de plus élevés quand je n'en sais rien
je me suis jamais allé le théâtre chez
le pic mais il n'y a rien de plus élevé
peut-être mais moi je voulais vous dire
que le théâtre chez les pics mais il n'y
a rien de plus élevé mais enfin vous
m'ennuyer avec vos piles mais qu'est ce
qui vous arrive
oh là là j'ai pas été mauvais non
qu'en pensez vous j'aurais jamais dû
leur faire mes imitations salle aura
complètement détraqué au cerveau au jour
mango casini bonjour mon vieux casimir
ça alors françois est devenu monsieur du
snob et monsieur du snop françois et oui
on va vous jouer tous les deux nous ne
sont pas passés l'un pour l'autre ma
chère amie mais ça a marché
oui mais oui mais par avec vous ça ne
marche pas je vous assure ça ne marche
pas c'est à moi que tu parles casimir
tutu vous voit maintenant oui ça va ça
va je vous ai parfaitement reconnue je
sais très bien que vous êtes le facteur
aux deux émirs walla walla
[Musique]